Please welcome Liam Cunningham, Gwendoline Christie,
Alfie Allen, Sophie Turner, Nathalie Emmanuel,
Jacob Anderson, Conleth Hill, John Bradley,
and Isaac Hempstead Wright
(audience cheering and applauding)
("Game of Thrones Intro")
How are you?
Hi there, hello, hello.
Sorry, we'll switch.
We'll switch real fast.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
You're gorgeous.
Here they are!
We have so much to talk about,
and I want to make sure we cover everything.
First of all, this is not just a mania
in the UK or in this country.
This is worldwide.
Liam, you said that the cast had a chance
to experience how insane it is.
You were at a soccer game in Spain.
Correct?
That's right.
That's absolutely correct.
This is where you got a sense of just how
truly global this madness is.
Overwhelmingly global, yeah.
We were in Seville, filming in Seville in Spain.
And we were very kindly invited along to
a wonderful football match at Barcelona,
one of the biggest games in the world.
We were in the hospitality suite, which they had repainted.
And they took some photographs, a little bit of video,
before the match started.
As the crowd filled up they said look who's in the house.
They played the music, showed shots of us there,
and then all of a sudden we heard,
they played the title track, the theme song.
The weirdest thing was hearing 80,000 people
singing along at a football match.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
These guys could do that!
How does it go?
Lead 'em!
La la.
Ba ba ba ba, ba ba ba.
(crowd singing along)
(laughing)
[Conan] La la la.
Very good!
I have to say.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
You were mostly good, but some of you were awful.
I just want to make that clear.